okay I'm going to talk to you about
balancing equations now this comes in
helpful in loads and loads of different
aspects of science so it's a really
important skill and I'm going to show
you a technique of how to go about doing
it okay so what an equation basically is
is we start off with the reactants these
are the things that react together to
begin with and on this side we have uh
products these are the things that are
produced in a reaction so this
particular reaction is showing that
methane and oxygen are reacting together
they are the reactants to produce carbon
dioxide and water these are the products
please notice how this is an arrow and
not an equal sign because our arrow is
showing that there's a chemical reaction
taking place to get from these to these
now the reason why we balance equations
is because atoms are never created or
destroyed they're just moved from one
state into another state or another
arrangement so we can't have atoms just
popping into existence or popping out of
existence so how do we go about
balancing equation now the first thing
that we do is we separate the two sides
of the equation so we separate our
reactants from our products what we do
next is we see how many of each atom we
have on each side of the equation so we
can see here I have one carbon I have
four hydrogen's and I have two oxygens I
know I've got one carbon rather than
four carbons because if I had four
carbons there'd be a little number four
there remember if we just see an atom by
itself like this there's just one of
them on this side I could see I've got
one carbon now I've got to be careful
here because I've got two oxygens here
I've also got one oxygen there so that's
a total of three oxygens and on this
side I've got two hydrogen's now another
quick thing I've seen a lot of students
getting confused and thinking well how
do I know how many different elements
this is here I'll use this is a little
example now if whenever we have an
element it always starts with a capital
so I can see that here if I've got a
capital C and a capital o I know I have
two different atoms
however because there's more elements
than there are letters in the alphabet
not every single element can have its
own capital letter so this here for
example cobalt has got a lowercase own
next to it because it's a lowercase o I
know that this belongs to that capital C
so whereas this is carbon and oxygen
with two capital letters this is one
atom of cobalt so remember that when
we're looking at our balancing okay so
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to take it one atom at a time and try
and balance this equation because at the
moment this is impossible I've got four
hydrogen atoms in my reactants and only
two in my products
now these couldn't have just popped out
of existence so I need to think about
how to do this so now lots of people try
and balance this straight away by doing
this they put in these little numbers
because now look I've got four m-80s on
this side and four X on this side and
I've got three oxygens on this side and
I've got three oceans on this side you
cannot do it like this okay now the
reason why that is is we knew the
reaction that we have trying to balance
we've made carbon dioxide and water
water is not h4 o so we never ever put
in little numbers similarly we know
we've reacting oxygen but we've said
here that we've tried to put in a 3 now
O 3 is actually an ozone molecule not
oxygen so we can never put in little
numbers instead we've got to the only
places I can put numbers is butts before
each of these different molecules so
it's at the beginning of each one
because what we can say is we've got to
lots of an h2o molecule so let's have a
look first of all my carbons they're
balanced so I'm going to leave them for
now next up my hydrogens now they're not
balanced so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to put a number in front of this
hydrogen - so what now saying is I've
got to lots of h2o molecules so now what
I need to do is update this to see how
many hydrogens I have in total so now on
this side I have four
hydrogen's to h2so4 in total and I also
have two oxygens here and two oxygens
here so I now have four here okay so
remember this it's two lots of h2 and
it's two lots of oh so that's how we do
it multiply a nice one so next up we
have a look through now carbons are
balanced good hydrogens are balanced
good oxygens are balanced no they're not
so I can see I need more oxygens on this
side in my reactants as a result
remember there's only to play only I can
only put numbers in front of a molecule
so I'm going to put a 2 right here to
make it - OH - so now in total I have
four oxygens good now quickly check is
it balanced carbons are balanced
hydrogens are balanced oxygens are
balanced well done I've managed to
balance my equation
so just to recap first of all split your
reactants of your products see how many
of each after we have on each side
remember you could never ever put in
little numbers you can only put numbers
before molecules make sure each and
every item is balanced and then welder
you can balance an equation